the second episode of halo is finally
available and fans are already scouring
each frame to find every hidden game
reference did you spot them all here are
the easter eggs you missed in halo
episode 2.
the second episode of halo starts with a
flashback to master chief's youth as the
spartan recruits the young john is shown
confronting one of his close friends a
trainee named sorin who's trying to
escape reach it's revealed that jon
originally planned to leave with him but
doesn't go through with the desertion in
the end it's at that point that jon
shows mercy to his fleeing friend you've
got five minutes
and then i'm waking up the entire camp
he may not appear in the video games but
sauron does appear in the short story
collection halo evolutions specifically
he's the main character of a story
titled pariah which follows him from a
brutal outer colony upbringing being
experimented on by dr halsey soren's
body reacts negatively to the spartan
augmentations leaving his body deformed
and like in the show he eventually
chooses to defect
halo evolutions never confirms what
happens to soren after being shot down
by the unsc during his escape attempt
the show on the other hand reveals that
he actually managed to get away and
build a life for himself away from
prying eyes
many of the other returning characters
in halo make their game connections
obvious players will quickly recall dr
katherine halsey captain jacob keys and
of course master chief himself however
there are a couple of characters in the
unsc that only fans will recognize
one of those characters is admiral
margaret parangoski dr halsey's direct
superior farngoski has her origins in
the halo books but she appears in a few
of the games as well her role in the tv
series is as director of the unsc's
office of naval intelligence easier to
miss is lord hood one of the highest
ranking officers of the unsc who first
appears in a conversation with dr halsey
while he isn't named shots during the
council meeting show that he wears a
name tag with hood written on it beyond
just characters there are several places
fans will also recognize after going
rogue master chief takes quan ha to the
place he believes she'll be safe the
rubble a renegade human colony built in
an amalgam of asteroids the rubble
appears most prominently in the novel
halo the coal protocol in the book many
of the rebels inhabitants are refugees
from madrigal which seems to be
referenced in the show by kwan's arrival
there however there are a lot of
differences between the rubble of the
old halo cannon and the show for
starters in the coal protocol the rubble
isn't just inhabited by humans but also
by the kigiar one of the member species
of the covenant secondly the colony in
the book is largely operated by an ai
called giuliana lastly and perhaps most
significantly the rubble is ultimately
destroyed by the covenant in the books
forcing its residents to flee the
kingyard plotline and the eventual
destruction of the rubble could
eventually take place in the halo series
as well but that remains to be seen
after reuniting with soren on the rubble
master chief is introduced to a man
named wrath a human who was driven mad
after being imprisoned by the covenant
it's implied that wrath was experimented
on and possibly even tortured all as
part of the covenant's mission to
discover and utilize forerunner
artifacts wrath even makes an important
revelation what is that ring a door
though he doesn't call it a halo he
clearly understands that it's a weapon
of genocidal proportions interestingly
reth is actually a reference to the
novel halo the coal protocol in the book
wrath is the name of one of the leaders
of the khigyar who engaged in trading
operations with the humans of the rubble
he's a treacherous and scheming covenant
commander who ultimately causes problems
for both factions and it's certainly an
interesting choice for the show to name
a human after him ref could simply be an
easter egg for fans who've read the halo
books but his name could also foreshadow
a darker role in the episodes to come
finally at the end of the episode when
master chief turns himself in to the
unsc there's a brief glimpse in mention
of a frigate called the stalwart dawn in
the video game halo reach the stalwart
dawn takes part in the defense of the
eponymous planet from a surprise attack
by the covenant things don't end well
for the humans on reach and the
inclusion of the stalwart dawn could be
a hint to things to come the fall of
reach is one of the most important
events in the entire halo timeline so it
seems inevitable that it will be brought
into the show eventually
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]